hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the ftx
crypto cup this is round one and uh
these are rapid games of course players
will be playing four games against each
other uh first clash we are going to
show is pragananda versus alireza firuja
and uh i will not be pronouncing it
pragyananda uh any longer as i pronounce
that pragnanda uh when i first started
making videos then someone contacted me
via email said it was actually
pragyananda and of course i believed
them and now i have been contacted again
and uh they said that actually the first
one was correct only i stressed it
poorly it's the stress goes on the first
not not on the second na so it's
actually pragnanda all right so i will
be pronouncing it that way as of this
video so if this uh if you guys have any
uh addition to this uh please do send me
an email and i will of course consider
it but um
i i i do believe the the person that
sent this email uh so maybe i i i'm
maybe i'm uh you know i misunderstood
the the the previous emails uh but okay
uh it's
versus alireza furuja uh let's check it
out these are rapid games and these are
rapid ratings you can see uh
rated 2755 uh 2751 uh which is very
incredible but um
rated much higher 27.93
so let's dive into this game it is
spectacular you guys will enjoy it and
especially since it comes from the
berlin defense uh pragnanda has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 with
e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop
to b5 the roy lopez is on the board
knight to f6 uh alireza goes for the
berlin defense we have castles offering
the rio gambit and here alireza accepts
the real gambit knight captures on e4
rook the e1 knights the d6 and knight
captures on e5 now this is nothing new
uh if you guys have been following
online chess for the past couple of
years uh you've seen this in every
online event pretty much bishop to e7 uh
with bishop back to f1 as now
uh there might be problems with our
bishop hanging on b5 so bishop to f1
knight captures on e5 rook captures and
now ali is a castle we have knight to c3
by prague uh knight to e8 and now knight
to d5 putting pressure on the bishop
here so bishop d6 kicking away the rook
for the moment already blocking his own
d7 pawn but he has plans of playing c6
moving the bishop and then advancing the
d-pawn so rookie one we have c6 chasing
away the knight knights to e3 and now
bishop to e7
and now knight to f5 going after the
dark square bishop once again bishop to
g5 we have d3 and now there is a game
where uh sorry where bishop captures and
c1 was played but here we have d5 by
alireza and it is now as of move 14 that
we have a completely new game and now i
would like to
uh say something but i will wait uh
until we check out a few more moves uh
and there's a very good reason for that
so
we have bishop captures on g5 prague
traits here queen captures alireza
brings the queen into the game threatens
to pick up the knight here so 97 check
uh king the h8 and now knight captures
on c8 eliminating the light square
bishop we have rook captures and now uh
pawn to c4 by prague uh going after the
d5 pawn if all it is a trace this is
nothing special then it's perfectly fine
the white queen controls the d file the
white roof controls the uh the e file so
instead knight to f6 pro alireza
activates the
knight with queen to b3 now attacking
the pawn on b7 and alireza goes for the
counter attack he plays queen to f4
saying okay you capture the pawn on b7
but if you do this knight g4 and you are
getting checkmated there's no
uh stopping this with both f pawn and h2
uh hanging so uh prague kicks away the
queen pawn to g3 the queen has to move
back queen to c7 up defending the pawn
and now queen to a3 uh
putting pressure on the a7 pawn and also
making room for the b pawn to start
marching forward that can be quite
deadly
as we've seen in the past so here pawn
uh pawn to c5 and now uh alvarez uh and
now prague just plays c captures on d5
and see captures on d5 is a move uh that
is uh according to the engine just um
almost uh on on uh you know uh it says
that black cannot play this position
it's it's just incredibly difficult to
continue playing this and remember when
i told you that after a completely new
game i was going to tell you something
but i i didn't want to you know ruin the
fun uh uh from that moment until this
moment prague played pretty much the the
top engine move every move he played and
he continues to do so now so c captures
on the e5
knight captures on d5 and now rook 8 to
c1 again absolute strongest saying that
you will not be defending the the c pawn
d4 is coming b4 is coming and your queen
here is very poorly placed point being
if let's say b6 is played uh now the
queen also guards the a7 pawn we just
play d4 and you can't uh defend against
this so for example knight f6 uh there's
bishop h3 we kick away one of the
defenders of the c5 pawn and that's it
for example rook c38 we're gonna play
captures capture so you you win the pawn
here and after b captures rook captures
you are now up upon and you have um well
uh
a very a very uh winning position uh
rook to e1 seems like it could be a
problem but we played bishop to f1 and
now it's okay for example if queen b7 or
queen c3 guards the pawn attacks the
rook threatens the rook to c8 so white
is uh
absolutely dominating this position so
instead after rookie the c1 already
played queen to b6 uh now everything is
still defended and at least the queen
moves away from the c file but now rook
to e5 another incredible move by prague
attacking the knight and also indirectly
putting pressure on the c5 pawn and here
already has to play something but there
really aren't uh any good moves he
played knight to b4 which seems like uh
it might be playable it prevents the
uh it prevents prague from actually
starting to capture on c5 uh but feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find an absolutely crushing move for
prague while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting our good
friend the bishop all the way back on f1
as he has a major role to play in this
as usual he always you know just comes
out of nowhere and starts laughing about
the position uh and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is pawn
to d4 that's how we finally go after the
c5 pawn elitist tried to save it but it
just didn't work point being if c
characters on d4 now rook b5 and black
resigns you're going to lose the knight
there's no
way for you to save it it's now attacked
twice you have to move the queen
there's just nothing you can play here
it's um
it is just a terrible terrible position
for black so instead after d4 knight
back to c6 there really aren't any good
moves here and now rook e captures on c5
you could also capture with the pawn uh
prague decides to capture with the rook
and now he does have a past d-pawn and
of course knight captures is impossible
because we just uh
win the rook and c8 so rook c to d8
putting pressure on the pawn now but now
pawn to d5 uh
pro pass pawn starts marching forward
knight to e5 and now queen to c3 uh
tripling up on the c file attacking the
knight uh preparing rook to c8 pretty
much in every line that exists and now
already uh can show why he is rated
almost 2800 can he save this so rook
after e8 defending the knight and here
prague plays h3 and this is um
something that i thought was very cool
when uh when
peter lecko said uh sorry i for some
reason i haven't updated the quote above
the board uh probably because i saved my
uh preset before actually uh changing
the quote but yeah i actually wanted to
use this quote by leico peter
he says that if you try to deny your
opponent all uh
i have three else in all but okay a
whole counter play you might end up
giving him some and this is what he
meant here
okay there could be some trouble if
knight comes to g4 then there might be
some problems with it with the f2 pawn
uh so that's why prague played h3 but he
didn't want to allow alireza to think
too much about the position because they
are both very much low on time
but for example after bishop to b5 there
is no
way to save this game for all it is the
rook is hanging and it doesn't matter
what you do the rook can never move away
from the back rank otherwise just rook
to c8 and if you try something like
knight d7 we happily trade and again go
rook to c8 it's just very very simple to
win this rook v8 characters captures
queen e5 and the past pawn will be uh
completely winning with the black king
being so far away on h8 but okay uh this
requires time and this is rapid chess so
you don't have all the time in the world
probably played uh h3 we have queen to
d6 and now bishop the g2 defending the
pawn here pawn to h5 all it is has to
play something
with h4 he might create some counter
play and now just rook to c7 again
playing the absolute strongest chest
just putting pressure on black's
position uh also the b7 pawn is hanging
so uh situation on the clock uh prague
three minutes alireza two minutes and
already plays rook to b8 you might get a
bit more counter play with h4
but uh he says he might still be able to
actually uh play this you know
objectively and just defends the pawn so
queen to a3 project says all right let's
trade queens and then i'm just gonna
start pushing my pass pawn all it is of
course declines this and now pawn to d6
we have queen to d4 uh and now queen to
c5 again uh prague offers a queen trade
alireza declines place queen captures on
b2 and now pawn to f4 now you could just
push the d7 point right away but just
point to f4 the h5 pawn will fall so
knight to g6 queen captures on h5 with
check king to g8 and now the beautiful
bishop to d5 uh so what do you play here
uh here uh alireza tries to trick prague
uh maybe into into
uh messing up the position he plays rook
to f8 and now it seems like it's a free
knight queen captures on g6 you can't
capture because of the bishop but
actually queen before check and it's a
draw if king h2 we just capture on the
five next queen d2 check and you will
not be able to win this position with
white any longer but here uh prague
immediately spots this place king to h1
now comes queen to f6 and now we have
pawn to d7 and now okay here queen to d6
going after the pawn the rogue the
bishop but everything is nicely
protected the queen doesn't really do
all that much so bishop to e4 uh prague
finds the absolute cleanest way to win
this he wants to play queen to f5 put
pressure on h7 and then just play h4 and
h5 and there is no way that you can stop
this we have rook b to d8 now comes
queen to f5 now threatening h4 and h5
queen to a3 going after the g3 pawn and
now
uh
you know in the absolute coolest wave
just plays king to h2 he gives up one
more pawn he's going to defend his king
with the rook
and that's it queen captures rook to c2
blocks this queen to a4 and now pawn to
h4 and he was in this position before h5
even landed on the board uh that already
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here as soon as he plays
anything and really there's nothing to
play i mean there is no good move for
black or even a bad move
there's no like you play a5 or anything
h5 is coming i mean and they're gonna
lose the knight and you're gonna get
checkmated or you move the knight and
you get checkmated right away so those
are basically your options so this was
truly an incredible game especially
since it was a rapid game i if you if
you remember there's an old saying uh i
i think uh i have no idea who said it
but it's it was like something i played
the opening like a book the middle game
like a magician and the end game like a
machine
well here prague played the opening uh
definitely like a book he played the
middle game like a machine and by the
time or rather there was no end game i
mean this is not an end game so
brock played the opening like a book and
he played the middle game like a machine
and that's it that's basically the story
of this game uh so uh that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it the first game
that we have covered from the uh ftx
crypto cup uh a lot more to come i hope
they are
at least as good as this one because
this was just amazing especially since
it comes from the berlin defense uh so i
hope to see many more uh i would like to
thank nagarjuna ponogoti peter rodriguez
alex vercilio francis air and ricky
yamini for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup uh until it ends most likely
uh so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day